[Music]
well this is the last day of campaigning
for both presidential candidates and
they are pulling out all the stops in
the battleground states President Obama
I know if you saw the this on the news
today he brought Bruce Springsteen on
Air Force One today to a rally in Ohio
and not to be outdone mit romney hosted
a star-studded republican event in
virginia here's the promo for the big
mitt romney event democrats have all the
big celebrities right
tonight at George Mason University in
Virginia Mitt Romney presents the prof a
new bration last-minute elections
featuring meatloaf Kid Rock 10 anujan
convoy victory Jackson hit rock and many
Tina Turner plus special guest
Buckethead Mary Lou Retton Marcus
Bachmann former NFL punter Tom tupa
Mexican Colonel Sanders the dog for
modern fan
Hurley from lost Patricia Heaton comedy
from Dennis Rodman junior music from the
Angie Harmon band and DJ Gary Pasadena
wants the hand from hamburger
raishin locksmith election celebrity
first 200 guests are eligible to win a
meet and greet with in romney source
george costanza smile and a guy dressed
like the constitution but don't worry if
you know when you'll still be able to
rub elbows with the likes of Toretto and
Stephen Baldwin smashmouth to battle y
AC green downtown Julie brown and the
handle the turtle from Breaking Bad
movie stars Cody
[Applause]